[російською] Коли розпочалась
Друга світова війна?
[російською] Що?
[російською] Коли розпочалась
Друга світова війна?
[російською] Волинська різня була...
[російською] Коли розпочалась
Друга світова війна?
[російською] В 1941-му.
Його побили і обкидали курячими яйцями.
Нардепа закидали яйцями та
застосували проти нього силу.
Яєчну атаку цього дня пережив
в Миколаєві Олег Царьов.
[російською] Влада створює
бойові загони.
[російською] Тому що вони
розуміють, що ані міліція,
ані інші правоохоронні органи
їх захищати не будуть.
Царьов — фашист!
[російською] Коли Друга
світова війна розпочалась?
Під вечір, оговтавшись
після такого прийому,
Олег Царьов написав на
своїй сторінці у Фейсбуці,
що в нього кидались
камінням, а міліції не було.
Хоча на відео чітко видно правоохоронців.
На цьому неприємності
у Царьова не завершилися.
Стало відомо, що
прокуратура закидає йому
посягання на територіальну
цілісність країни.
[російською] Зовнішнє управління...
Зовнішнє управління... Зовнішнього управління...
[російською] Ну вибачайте, зараз скажу,
це моя персональна думка.
[російською] Те, що Україна — унітарна країна — помилка.
[російською] Ось це відео, так.
[російською] Добре. Ну, і що?
[російською] Вибачте, будь
ласка, у вас член є?
[російською] Ви іноді член поправляєте?
[російською] Ну, це механічний рух.
[російською] Питання:
ви готові пройти поліграф?
[російською] Звісно! Очманіти,
а поліграф готовий пройти мене?
[російською] Послухайте, не ви мені
будете говорити, як говорити.
[російською] Ми, українці
і росіяни, — один народ.
[російською] Таке питання:
що б Ви порадили
[російською] робити зі своїм
іміджем народному депутатові,
[російською] про якого всі
кажуть, що він тупий?
[російською] Ще раз повторіть,
будь ласка.
Для цього ми прийшли в політику.
Для цього ми отримали вашу довіру.
Вашу довіру для боротьби.
Проти України і проти
українського народу.
Сьогодні вже встановлюється новорічна...
...йолка.
[російською] Зупиніться!
[російською] Кажу, «батя, я стараюсь».
Територію нашої держави треба зробити
небезпечною для життя наших громадян.
А, безумовно, коли до нас
поїдуть гості, тим паче.
[російською] У Медведчука
є свої власні переконання.
[російською] Я вважаю, що він український націоналіст.
До відльоту на Батьківщину Владімір Путін заїхав до свого кума Медведчука.
Колишній глава адміністрації президента
зустрічав Путіна разом зі своєю родиною
на порозі свого розкішного
особняка на березі моря.
Вам не здалося, це
справжній залізничний перон.
Станція «Дальняя».
Цікаві штучки.
Хотів сказати, що він українець.
І цукор.
Важко уявити, де олігарх Медведчук
дістав цукор часів СРСР.
Хочете цукру?
[російською] Росія стрімко вертається
в голодні 90-ті роки.
[російською] Забуте слово «дефіцит»
знову увійшло в лексикон.
[російською] За можливість придбати
декілька кілограмів цукру,
[російською] люди б'ються,
в прямому сенсі цього слова.
[російською] Щойно на спорожнілих полицях
[російською] знову з'являються
паковання з цукром,
[російською] покупці
змітають їх в лічені хвилини.
у нашій YouTube-спільноті]
[російською] Влада прагне,
щоб не було багатих.
[російською] Ми хочемо,
щоб не було бідних.
[російською] Жінки потрібні
в політиці для того,
[російською] щоб не дати помаранчевим порушувати права жінок та дітей.
[російською] НАТО в Україні не буде!
[російською] За референдум у нас вже
чотири з половиною мільйони підписів.
[російською] Я вам
російською мовою кажу:
[російською] я не дам з України робити ядерне кладовище.
[російською] Це Вам.
[російською] Це не Росія підняла ціну на газ, це ви з нею не змогли домовитися.
[російською] Юро, не переймайся,
ми переможемо, я фартовий!
[російською] Влада без опозиції неминуче
породжує культ особистості.
[російською] Ось так і працюємо, працюємо для вас.
[російською] Опозиційний блок «Не Так».
[російською] Наш номер
у виборчому бюлетені — 44.